is our universe infinite sooner or later
this question is certain to occur to
many of you unfortunately today's
science is incapable of providing a
definite answer to it but it can claim
with assurance that there was a
beginning of the universe the world we
know has been growing and developing
throughout 13.8 billion years
originating from the condition that came
to be called the cosmic singularity in
order to research this process
astronomers have to literally look back
in the past when we talk about the
boundaries of the universe we imply only
the limits seen to us this visible area
is called the meta galaxy or the
observable universe but what lies beyond
[Music]
the statement that there are boundaries
to the universe is considered per se one
of those great ideas which are able to
dramatically change our world perception
something similar took place back in
1543 when Nicholas Copernicus proved
that the earth wasn't located in the
center of the cosmos the following
breakthrough took place in the 20th
century when Edwin Hubble showed to the
world that galaxies moved away from each
other this prompted the idea that the
universe hasn't existed eternally and
was formed as a result of a certain
event the Big Bang today we are certain
that the dimensions of the world we'll
live in are much larger than we are
capable of imagining the search for the
answer to the question about its
boundaries is going to lead to yet
another scientific breakthrough at the
moment scientists are able to talk only
of the boundaries within which the
objects are visible this area is also
called the observable universe that is
it's part which is the absolute past in
relation to the observer
the cosmic horizon is the boundary of
the observable universe the objects on
the horizon become infinitely redshifted
that is they constantly move further
away the number of galaxies within the
observable universe is estimated at
upwards of 500 billion with this number
increasing on a regular basis as the
research equipment becomes more advanced
but how big is the observable area of
the universe today the distance to the
remotest observable objects equals
approximately 14 billion parsecs in all
directions thus the observable universe
is a sphere with a diameter of about 93
billion light years and with the center
inside the solar system that is it is
centered on the observer the area equals
350 Quinn vision Tilian cubic meters it
should be mentioned that the light
emitted by the furthermost observable
objects has been traveling for 13.8
billion light years before reaching us
however the distance to those objects
has significantly grown due to the
never-ceasing expansion of the universe
this process is the result of their
being matter and energy in space filling
space-time while there is matter in
space there is gravitational force
therefore the universe either shrinks
affected by gravity or expands affected
by dark matter it is also worth noting
that there isn't a single Center for the
universe's expansion just like there
isn't a space for the universe to expand
into beyond its boundaries
this process takes place with the matter
in space at any point everywhere and at
all times we do not physically perceive
this as the force holding our atoms and
molecules together does not allow us to
burst under the influence of the space
expansion this may be compared to a
baking loaf of bread with the raisins
four galaxies and similar formations and
the dough for the space matter according
to estimates the distance to the
furthermost observable objects today
equals approximately 14 Giga far sex or
46 billion light years the furthermost
stellar system with respect to the earth
is a galaxy dubbed GN z xi it's light
has been traveling to us for about
thirteen point four billion years
meaning that this object was formed less
than 400 million years after the Big
Bang however due to the constant
expansion of the universe
today's distance to GN said 11 is
approximately 32 billion light years one
may argue that the speed with which it
recedes exceeds the speed of light but
it does not clash with a special theory
of relativity as it isn't the matter
that is receding but the space between
the two objects is growing larger this
object is supposedly one of the very
first galaxies and is likely to be the
closest stellar cluster to the edge of
the observable universe if man were able
to freely travel from one world to
another it is in that galaxy that we
might find out about the genesis of our
world in more detail what we call the
Mater galaxy is likely to have started
to expand immediately on its birth in
theory the boundaries of the matter
galaxies may well reach the cosmic
singularity that is it may show us what
the world had been like before the Big
Bang but in practice it is relic
radiation that is the limit to the
observable it is this radiation that is
emitted by the furthermost of G
in the universe two have been observed
in contemporary science this radiation
poses something like a barrier for our
vision it came about approximately
380,000 years after the Big Bang that is
at the time when the universe cooled off
sufficiently for atoms to emerge in
plain English it is similar to an image
of space in its childhood where it is
depicted before the formation of the
first stars it is likely that the
universe stretches infinitely beyond
this barrier and it is there that it's
hypothetical boundaries are to be found
but the objects beyond this barrier are
referred to in a number of ways
multiverse objects parallel universe
objects to name but to science today is
incapable of defining these bodies with
any detail however assuming that the
universe carries on expanding we may
conclude that the objects were able to
observe now are sooner or later going to
disappear from our field of vision
if the accelerating expansion of the
universe continues indefinitely the
galaxies beyond our super cluster are
sooner or later going to recede beyond
the horizon as a result thus becoming
invisible to us any form of
communication beyond the boundaries of
the observable universe will be rendered
impossible and any contact between the
objects will be lost of the earth the
solar system
the Milky Way and our super cluster will
be mutually observable whereas the rest
of the universe will recede in the
distance there may be hypothetical
worlds beyond the regions observable to
us as they originate as a result of
phase transitions of physical vacuum
alternatively there may be objects
forming out of irregularities of relic
radiation located closest to the
particle horizon the question of
multiverse objects remains a bone of
contention among scientists prompting an
overwhelming number of pseudo scientific
guesses be it as it may most researchers
see eye to eye as to the infinity of our
universe
although they interpreted in different
ways some of them claim our worlds to be
multi-dimensional which makes our
three-dimensional universe merely one of
its layers others are inclined to
believe in the theory of a multi
universe with us as a miniscule fraction
of an infinite multitude whereas there
may be a portal to other worlds beyond
the observable area of the universe some
space theories involve the existence of
the sacred event horizon according to
this concept we're never going to be
able to look beyond the event horizon
because the speed at which photons
travel away from us will be higher than
the speed with which the observable
universe expands according to this
theory all the galaxies surrounding us
abound to recede beyond the event
horizon it will look like time stopped
in them we will observe them infinitely
receding beyond the observable
boundaries but never quite disappearing
from view be it as it may contemporary
science cannot provide a definite answer
to this question although the situation
may change overnight once we have
developed more advanced observation
equipment the universe might turn out to
be a sort of sphere and traveling over
it might remind one of traveling on the
spherical surface of our earth
considering the scale it reaches however
this prospect appears impossible in
order to reach the edge of the
observable universe it would take man 46
billion years even if we travel at the
speed of light
by the time we reached this designated
point it would have moved the same
distance away and a similar journey
would have to be embarked upon it is
likely that there aren't any large
objects beyond the observable universe
and on peering there we would see just a
homogeneous cloud of helium hydrogen and
a few other elements however we might
probably never be able to discover the
origins of our world
and might forever remain in the position
of someone chasing the horizon I hope
you have enjoyed this video if you have
why not hit the like button and
subscribe this way you will not miss the
new videos keep in touch
[Music]
you